ви є батальйону азів і в incident
купіть рвався на фугасі минуло уроку
равлик поглибить маленький на фронт вин
пішов добровольцям із чим вранці це
статус учасника ато та пенсію через
інвалідність гум вдавалося та провести
багатому води ну кабінетах чиновники
доводиш і що вина трава в пір вона не
на фронті будинках тисяч держави право на
соціальне замовлення
буллу нелегко проте за раз і внж і врятував
ведмедик з року їх удіне кабінетами
домовилася сказала даємо to be no good
група інвалідності другові на рік ну так
мани через ось коротше вирости нога
я просто ящірка там універсальний боєць
туман і вирости нога коротша за основу
побіжу кудись через місяць
знав точне оформлення в це
документи щоб у нас тут нам уроки
вранці це дасин і виплачено компенсацію
через занапащене здоров'я
геть осях а я звикла дієти вилицювату
іншу тисячу євро
риту видно і закону просто за хост
учасникам ато та руди нам за гиблих
солдатик навіть у павича треба вати і
приблизно 20 різьблених перед однак на сюди
назад у і джеррі поправкою до закону
зручності про писання на читку там у
правозахисні організації за раз
буквально завали не з картами tedx кому
держава поки що так і не дала допомогу
позиція держави і до нас це на всьому
інструкції піджаку не акту та келмо жити
розум оживають люду і верхні права c
владне виду броджу цю позицію держав
ще багата чого нам битися ти алла мій ж
ніщо момент від мінсоцполітики ви знаєте
що формат і приспали гаї виплат це
компенсації пак не їж сотні тисяч
солдатів і у встановлені в морі у всіх
регіонах України
а ось і дружина мало за протиток орди на
тіні центри їх з перу hipster
по ікла не до допомагати учасникам ато
то пологи нам закрив їх відриву від і
соціально допомогу курять ви знаєш
утримання шкрябати знайду стаття врослий
для повноти нам із забезпечення учасники
бойових дінас ході україни
в 1 годину оля заповнюючу робот з ним було
б задавлені ти потребу учасники бойових
дій на сході України так на ставку не
свята для учасників ато за розривав і
45 тисяч гектарів землі то ви робили 2
на 5 мільйонів євро на придбання квартир
кілька місяців тому є пін-код
віконце криму у службу квартиру за 50
кілометр вид краєва вельможі худі ти і
у нього та робота у ремонт на музику
батальйону
однак для багатих учасники ато який
прикуйте ту лише до
на обличчі та недоступним